[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
avec jean charles lajoie de libon jours
éditeurs florence marcadet avocate au
barreau de versailles jean patrice anne
charlotte d'eysines à ses bons jours
monseigneur de droit public elle fêtait
droit et alain gournac bonjour vous êtes
sénateur honoraire désigne non d'une
horaire c'est comme ça qui est alors la
dernière fois que vous étiez venu
projective partir en heroes vous êtes
allé en iran et évidemment c'est un
voyage
c'était un voyage privé il faut dire
mais étonnement privé cette fois ci mais
cette fois-ci oui parce que ça existe
déjà à l'est par le passé pour le
travail mais évidemment c'est un pays
dont on parle beaucoup parce que c'est
au centre des discussions notamment
après le rejet par trempe de l'accord
sur le nucléaire iranien
alors peut-être qu'on va commencer avec
vous sur vos impressions de voyage en
iran
je vais essayer de me virer parce que je
suis rentré ébloui par dire en parle à
personne
il faut être franc voilà 19 ans 19 20
ans je m'intéresse à la perse comme les
mayas je suis atterré ya pas mal de
choses mais la paire c'est quelque chose
qui était en moi marquer j'ai découvert
un pays magnifique
alors je dis tout de suite ici que je
suis pas allé soutenir le régime a fait
des choses soient claires il faut il
faut peut-être distincts créés dans le
piratage il s'agit d'ailleurs repris
d'ailleurs réussite et maintenant mon
analyse de retour et après réflexion
ils rencontreront le régime va
rencontrer de grandes difficultés qu'a
jeunesse cette jeunesse qui a toutes les
informations extérieures avec les
réseaux sociaux avec les poules qu'elle
va vouloir beaucoup plus de liberté et
ça il ya un décalage qui a dit qu'à
l'âge que j'ai
depuis que je suis ce pays qui était en
train de s'accélérer
vous avez le pouvoir qui est un trader
et puis vous avez la population la
jeunesse la jeunesse est très important
c'est un jeu c'est une personne sur deux
personnes sur deux et avec notamment il
ya la situation des femmes en iran
notamment et notamment les femmes sont
en majorité dans les universités enfin
c'est habituellement
alors j'ai tout de suite c'est un peuple
tout le monde le sait très intelligent
et musiciens histoire formidable c'est
un peuple
c'est un peuple raisons diverses et
finesse dans les analyses
i la deuxième chose que je vais vous
dire c'est que j'ai remarqué que ce
peuple faciaux nous avons rencontré
adore la france comme j'aime même peu
mon pays je veux pas les bras et et deux
pays'' et il ya des vérités
ils ont des informations sur loup
absolument incroyable il avait espoir
que le patron de la l'entreprise america
parce que c'est un patron d'entreprise
c'est pas de chef de l'état ne fasse pas
fait cette bêtise qu'il a réalisé une
semaine après mon retour on peut pas ou
ou trois occasions après vente ou alors
c'est embêtant parce que nous avons des
développements prévus
peugeot renault rire vous comprenez pour
le pays peugeot cake à peu près 40%
doublement du parc automobile vous avez
renault qui est en train de prendre un
petit 10 toulouse pour son incroyable
et puis vous avez cette fameuse commande
qui était réellement quand nous étions
avec le président du sénat et jean
pierre raffarin c'est sans un airbus
alors tout c'est quand même absolument
préoccupe tous est bloqué ou comment ça
se passera ou s'il ya un risque d'
amende à payer
oui parce que si vous voulez vous
américain alors je veux dire deux choses
la première c'est qu'on n'est pas en
direct
c'est pas jojo c'est par renault ça peut
nous aider à peut nous aider mais malgré
tout ça veut dire qu'il peut jouer et il
se retirer oui mais qui sortirait en
laissant patrick et pièces détachées
veut dire d'air
un ver leur renault chiffre à 1
pourquoi parce que c'est un problème de
dollars les réserves y redire en sont
faibles d'abord et deuxièmement il ya
bureau ils ont compris qu'il fallait
qu'ils aient une part de roue des
faibles vis-à-vis du dollar
et ça les banques c'est le problème du
banc banques françaises qui ne se feront
pas de pommes de risques ça ne risquent
des amendes élevées elle a eu par le
passé
enfin s'ils vont acheter des avions
chinois alors fait que ça à faire s'ils
peuvent pas faire boeing peuvent il peut
pas faire plus c'est incroyable quand il
reste que le chiffrement l'amérique
domine encore méconnue et combien
l'europe est faible et combien leur
préfère c'est beau de critiquer les
italiens vous va bien venu d'arrêter
tout ça si on veut enterrer l'europe et
de la mettre en difficulté parce que là
la réponse était d'être moins deux
derniers mois la réponse
qu'est ce que fait l'europe vise à vide
de l'approché de trompes
bon en même temps c'est pas non plus un
régime fabuleux donc on peut aussi
comprendre que ce ne soit pas le paradis
de commercer avec eux et c'est michael
de commerce avec eux c'est un peu les
soutenir aussi failli a en tout cas ça
fait débat peut faire de la grêle dans
là je vous confirme c'est par l'egypte
fabule douala ça d'ailleurs pesé non
c'est pas une fabuleuse ne peut pas
franchement sur l'a42 voiture est ce
qu'on ne peut pas rayer cet endroit du
monde même pour les américains je parle
même pas de business
je parle de d'équilibré global moi je
pense par exemple que le caucase est
quelque chose d extrêmement important on
occupe mais l'iran sera incontournable
donc il faut savoir ça il faut qu'on
prévoit un peu demain de regarder
comment faire et si on souhaite que les
enturbannés
qu'européennes les recherches parce que
surveille de très près contrairement ce
que dit trompe on surveille de très près
l'évolution de l'atome
on est très près ce qu'ils disent est
arrivé on savait exactement où il en
était et c'était très survie oui c'est
pour ça qu'il est de l'accord je suis
passé à côté d'une centrale mais il ya
le ton peuple
c'est aussi pour les fusées c'est aussi
pour les risques de 2d des fusées
iraniennes parce que ça c'est pas dans
l'accord ils peuvent continuer mais pas
pas
dans un ordre militaire mais pour
faiblissent ville était permis voilà
facilement de l'un à l'autre un mille
des craintes parce qu'on voit la carte
oui ça ne vous avez le skip et qu'ils
adorent oui c'est ça qui était il ya
peut-être ça aussi dans le dans leur
génome est rempli s'est avéré de la
parade erreur je suis allé dans un
marché j'ai demandé qu'est ce qui était
marqué il faut rayer de la carte israël
d quelle bêtise un pays qui voudrait
sortir et peser sur plan international
qui va nous dire demain qui va accepter
qu'israël disparaisse c'est une bêtise
là c'est vraiment on voit qu'ils sont
complètement bloqués loquet oui là
dessus dream et luiz mais c'est une des
raisons peut-être qui explique que le
rejet par 32 de l'accord je crois savoir
que c'est plus une raison que trompe a
été un peu et lui un petit peu et lui
brille par le scellé dès à présent temps
là bas et que c'est c'est important
c'est important et il est très proche de
moi je vais vous dire tergnier où je
n'accepterai jamais que touchera m bon
personne n'est d'accord pas bien
évidemment sur ce rejet de l'accord
nucléaire iranien moi ça se trouve pas
ça enfin si peut-être choquer notre ami
mais voyons pas ça si choquant que ça il
ya un moment on peut pas non plus
toujours accepter qu'un pays soit à
l'opposé des valeurs enfin
de ce qu'on aime de son soutien de ce
pourquoi on vote
et puis faire comme s'il se passait rien
en disant toujours bah oui mais comme ça
un jour ça finira par changer
bah oui mais ça change pas très vite
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est
que ça fait quand même des quelques
dizaines d'années clear en espèces de 2
chape de plomb monstrueuse et puis on
peut alors c'est bien le business mais
de dire ok et on va vous renoncez pas
d'accord avec c'est pas l'accord sur le
nucléaire
oui mais cette situation politique ça
rejoint un peu ça quand même donc
dernier moment où c'est pas un régime
auquel on peut pas avoir tellement
confiance en eux aux français on sait
très bien donc on peut avoir confiance
dans un pays qui a signé un traité puis
qui retire sa signature comme ça de
manière unilatérale c'est quand même un
peu choquant aussi non jeu il est en
train de se retirer de tout ce qui s'est
passé avant tout les tricote au fur et à
mesure qu'ils comptent pas qu'un
président qui s est adressé il a été élu
il tient ses promesses en cinq ans avait
justement sur le plan international des
règles internationales c'est un pays
comme ça pour retirer sera tiendra un
accord c'est un accord et non pas
rentable très épais c'est à dire qu'il
n'a pas été signée suivant les formes
qui aurait supposé un accord du congrès
et cetera 2 1 c'est un petit peu une
forme de gentleman agreement a été fait
entre entre président entre personnes en
réalité et donc c'est pour ça que donald
trump par un simple décret ne serait ce
que par une simple déclaration a pu
bousculer cet équilibre alors moi je
rejoins ce que tu dit jean-charles sur
sur la confiance qu'on peut faire dans
le régime iranien mais moi ce que je
crois c'est que les équipes sont très
fragiles au niveau du moyen-orient est
ce qu'on pouvait en tout cas donné comme
bon point à cet accord c'est qu'il avait
une forme de bon équilibre à mon sens
dans le donnant-donnant c'est à dire que
du coup et de réintégration
gracieuse de rendre le jeu avec
notamment cette idée de normaliser les
relations pour leur force et aussi à
avoir a autorisé le contrôle des états
unis alors que maintenant moi je me
demande qu'est ce qui lie les rangs pour
arrêter son nucléaire
alors vous l'avez dit pas si vilain mais
militaire elle est plus obligé par rien
donc je crois qu'on est en train de
bousculer déséquilibres profonds
notamment avec toute la situation aussi
des autres pays au moyen orient qui
peuvent créer des tensions tellement
forte que remettre en cause cet accord
c'est quand même dire beaucoup de choses
et annoncé un message assez négatif
c'est normal je voudrais ajouter je
partage tout jamais me reste que vous
aillez mais je pense pas du tout du jeu
mais il a peur il ya d'autres pays
concilier cet accord il emmène il efface
t il
il donne comme nul autre pays puisque ça
a été ça pas été traitées uniquement
août et a même qui a d'ailleurs c'est
pour ça qu'on a avancé
pardon de le dire pour nos amis
américains si je pense que l'iran a pu
avancer dans cette à ces points traités
dans cet accord bon d'accord d'accord
d'accord parce que il y avait d'autres
pays qui étaient partie prenante et
redoux qu'est-ce qu'on fait ou dit
troupe n'en veut plus et nous on a su
dire non
d'ailleurs on continue à être liés de
saint c'est à dire que toutes les autres
parties à l'accord continue ainsi l'ont
pas retiré leur il ya une volonté
d'ailleurs je trouve des états qui sont
restés dans la corde d'essayer de le
faire suivis alors comment est-ce que
l'iran va accepter déjà on a quand même
eu un mot du président qui entend dire
que ça commence à moins lui plaire
j'avoue qu'à mon sens avec la puissance
des états unis en moins à mon avis on
est en train de déconstruire fil à fil
cet accord qui qui qui risque de tomber
à l'eau ou en tout cas qui mérite d'être
négociées parce que je crois pas qu'on
peut rester sur ce qui démontre la
faiblesse de l'europe ce qui démontre la
faiblesse de rome
cet événement à mohamoud se consoler
l'occident tels que vous n'êtes quand il
est quand ils arrivent en iran le
regarde comment ça va aller je vends
comme avant parce que quand la ville
avait quitté la dernière fois j'avais un
rendez vous apporte sa patte bébé tu vas
en iran mais qui a réfléchi avant de
partir en mission sortie plus en
sécurité a dans tout mon voyage en iran
que ce que j'ai fait cette semaine à
saint-ouen pas tout puisque valérie
pécresse a décidé de s'y installer très
et j'allais au conseil régional chez
vous dire que je préfère y aller moi je
laisserai pas ma femme se balader quand
il fait noir
bon j'ai allongé ici le détacher si vous
vous dites votre question est importante
parce que on peut on peut s'emballer
mais globalement il ramène à quoi j'ai
essayé ne demeura -d coûte énormément ce
que dit ended énormément des traductions
puisque un moment on a rencontré des
familles pour savoir ce qu'ils étaient
mais ensuite j'ai regardé la qualité du
pays
j'ai des routes il pas qu'on peut pas
rouler ou alors que moi ils ont ils ont
dû faire des routes pour mon arrivée
[Rires]
gournac j'avais gardé alors un pas de
policiers comment vous raconte ça vient
pas très épais raté on n'y a pas de
policiers en uniforme alors je pense
c'est ce que je disais parce que la
fille me disait tu vous savez bon on
omet aussi nous si depuis en plus il
sans uniforme je pense rien de secret
bon propre un pays très propre et est un
pays qui connaît bien son histoire
la paire c'est quelque chose
d'incroyable c'est monté ça a été
jusqu'en il c'est c'était quelque chose
d'absolument incroyable et nous pas
oublier ça ils veulent compter parle de
la jeunesse à l'epad et les dirigeants
ils veulent compter et pour ça ils ont
la chance d'avoir un pays que je
considère comme magnifique disparu
cependant si vous êtes pouvait un jour
aller à 10 par an et c'est renversant
si renversant de beauté d'eau déquilibre
de longueur de la place de largeur et km
500 500 mètres de hauteur sur les côtés
c'est magnifique c'est quelque chose qui
m'a et j'étais avec mon épouse
j'écoute aussi ce qu elle ce qu'elle
ressent qui m'a bousculé web vers ces
femmes alors hôtellerie olala parfaite
restauration nous avons essayé de manger
de goûter la callas le local très bien
parce que tu vois bien épicée
qu'autrement dans sa quatre pays non moi
le haut niveau touristique touristique
au niveau touristique magnifique dans
vous conseiller le conseil
non mais c'est alors au delà au delà du
conseil de touristique c'est vrai c'est
bien de s'éveiller
des civilisations comme celle-là oui
vous avez raison la paix alors il ya je
ne sais pas si la thèse bernard henri
lévy est contesté mais didi que la paire
ces données de l'iran et l'iran c'est le
pays des aryens l'a raconté dans son
dernier livre sa thèse est contestée un
peu m'enfin c'est donc ce serait des
allemands qui auraient donné le nom
d'iran à l'iran alors que son vrai nom
c'est la personne interpellée
moi j'y suis allé dans la tête même dans
la vie young quand j'étais dans l'avion
à l'as tu vas découvrir la perse
c'était quand même net bon je vous dis
pas que porte découvert l'iran que c'est
pas vrai j'ai découvert vivant mais j'ai
senti par cette intelligence pas se
passer par cette histoire parts
elle a les contacts que j'ai eus écart
younès j'ai eu un contact formidable qui
a été fait un peu en dehors de ce que je
pouvais faire
bon la peta c'est un peuple qui soutient
pas
je vais vous dire j'ai pas en compte les
lycées ça il ya des rencontres il ya
comme un vent qui décide pour le régime
il n'y a quand même un fossé entre le
gouvernant le pouvoir et la société
est ce que vous dites c'est que au fond
ce fossé leur avis à grandir de père en
février
j'ai un fossé énorme énorme 1 et 6 alors
je peux me tromper
ces deux-là reviendra les difficultés
ils n'accepteront plus il avait un
modéré il avait poussé à modéré alors
les mots d'hier
terme aux dérives modéré quoi pas trop
modéré et alors si l'on y met beaucoup
d'espoir l'avant avant mon arrivée et
globalement il ya les libertés sur a
absolument bafoués alors je crois qu'il
ya aussi un peut-être aussi une
différence entre les villes la campagne
plus il ya une force peut-être enfin le
loup le pouvoir religieux tient sa force
si de certaines rabat ya des viandes le
passé dans des villages où c'est
totalement religieux les familles
sachent et beaucoup de comium beaucoup
de communautés qui sont présentés par
des petites régions est en réalité c'est
pas du tout un état fédéral mais il ya
quand même beaucoup de régions qui ont
beaucoup de forces qui ont beaucoup
d'argent également et et qui ont plutôt
envie d'être influencés par la tradition
et c'est pour ça que c'est à cause à mon
avis du système constitutionnel
qui existe depuis la révolution de 79
qu'on en est parvenu un système où la
religion gouverne et c'est ça qui en
ferme finalement les politiques dans un
système qui est complètement déconnecté
le guide de la réserve assure qui dort
et tous les jours ils savent ce qui se
passe in société allait s'avérer guerre
continue des manifestations c'était dans
ceux liés par les réservations en vain
mais ça a été réprimée par les
intéressés et brusquement s'applique
avait retiré son foulard
ils l'ont traîné par terre bien sûr
alors il ya aussi le problème de la faim
vous savez qu un défenseur de la femme
qui continuera à l'être
c'est quand même pas des gens pleins
c'est pas et avec sept quand même cette
chose est sélectionneur je crois qu'une
majorité de femmes qui suivent des
études supérieures enfin les très bonnes
équipes puisque je crois que c'est plus
de 70 et il ya des universités soixante
dix pour cent c'est énorme c'est énorme
et c'est pour ça qu'il ya des choses
quand même très contradictoires dans
cette dans cette société
c'était un accord par un traité le g7
alors par exemple 30 qu'ici et puis
après il prend l'avion et puis par un
tweet il dit finalement dans leur dos
tres c'est pareil le droit est là encore
c'était une déclaration commune
donc c'est quelque chose de alors de
contraignant mais à la fois qui a cette
force un peu personnel c'est aussi la
force du g7 c'est que normalement c'est
censé être dans un petit comité pour
essayer de discuter des grandes
orientations ils sont sept et alors le
la dénonciation par un tweet c'est quand
même une première c'est son entrée dans
le système constitutionnel ce que je
trouvais absolument original néanmoins
ça va bien avec le style de trump et du
coup on est vraiment complètement dans
la politique fiction et puis voilà japon
va devoir
voilà tu en as
comme on a vécu quand même là fallait
des accords attention les voilages ses
sauts mais tout ça un type qui dénonce
ce qui vient de signer dans l'avion par
tweet c'est quand même plein dans la vie
on dise où on apprenait qu i treva
d'accord jusqu'à canadien avait pas fait
le matin alors une fois que une fois que
le grand méchant est parti je sais c'est
un peu curieux aussi est-ce que c'est
réel c'est pas bon
notamment avec les italiens je vois pas
quelle gestion
bah oui c'est juste ridicule quand elles
vont se veut la guerre il ya le je crois
que c'est le valeurs actuelles qui
posait cette question
trump idiot ou génie à votre avis les 2
7 et 2 des deux bâillements ya un peu
plus de temps après il ya peu de tony
date dans ce qu'il est l'exact
illustration de ce qu avait énoncé
kissinger inquiète le conseiller de
nixon qui avait dit il ya une bonne
façon de faire de la politique c'est de
de jouer au fou et si on ne l'est pas et
tout le monde pense qu'on va l'être
qu'on l'ait vraiment et du coup tout le
monde a peur et tout le monde finit par
vous céder parce qu'on se dit ce type et
ce type est dingue mais c'est qu'ils
aient déjà décision n'est pas dingue on
gagne et c'est un peu comme ce que fait
tram je ne pense pas qu'on puisse cet
idiot comme le dit valeurs actuelles et
être président des états unis il ya
beaucoup de gens et pas le mot autour de
cette table sur mon nombreux à penser
que trump étonnamment 17 mai mais je
pense que ne peut pas dire à brody est
président des libéraux il ya peut-être
mal connaît bien valeurs actuelles
jenny bon y'a pas de problème c'est
idiot non c'était tout fou génial à voir
ces traductions mais c'est pas bon ce
panel a club de spectacle ou génie
politique enfin c'est un peu il ya un
mais à côté il a quand même la majorité
des chefs d'entreprises américains qui
sont pas tous des idiots ou des génies
qui soutiennent oui et alors il a le
soutien
il va probablement gagner les élèves et
le méthane oui la situation des états
unis économique est très bonne
est-ce que ça va durer parce qu'il
america firth était pour les américains
c'est important ça les cas first sur wii
parce que c'est tous pour votre pays
coincées savez j'ai quelqu'un qui va se
lever veut dire bah non mon pays il a
cette force
qu'ils aient qu'on croyait qu'il n'avait
jamais passé la primaire qui n'avait
jamais ensuite à trélut mais ce qu'il
avait dit ne ferai jamais ce qu'il avait
dit qu'il n'aurait aucun moyen de
remplir son programme je crois qu'il a
cette force de la surprise c'est que
finalement il a joué sa vie politique un
petit peu comme sa vie professionnelle
je pense qu'il est dit est allé au culot
il ya un côté ces mini des affaires
étrangères allemandes qu'il a qualifié
de cowboy et d'agents immobiliers avec
les défauts et les qualités des deux je
crois que c'est vraiment ça c'est à dire
que c'est quelqu'un qui qui va au culot
il l'a dit pour l'accord avec kim
jong-un je vais me sentir en à la
seconde je suis habituée aux relations
sociales et ya une force dans cela quand
même c'est que justement au moins il a
une vente de courage politique est due à
sa passion il y va avec une certaine
confiance en lui et une forme de
mégalomanie c'est pourquoi il a été
provisoirement fin bat il tant que tu
fais la politique qui les a promis
d'encre en espagne illustre cette nappe
c'est bien parce que même m
hier matin quand il dit avant la
décision de la l'attribution de la coupe
du monde la prochaine coupe du monde aux
états unis au canada et au mexique
il dit clairement mais c'est sorte de
chantage mais tel quel et des récipients
faites attention tous les pays qui vote
parce que nous on fait de l'argent si
vous votez mal on sort on va regarder
qu'ils votent pour qui en gros si vous
votez pas pour nous c'est fini les
subventions strict mais c'est du coup ce
matin faisaient bouillir c'est ont
baissé des états unis qui ont là qui on
découvre et je pense qu'il aurait fait
cette façon de faire face qui
normalement se faisait la vague ouais il
est plus cependant il est plus
moi je suis bien d'accord sur votre
analyse
moi c'est du bluff c'est des coups il
est plus quand on analyse son chef
d'entreprise milliardaire que nous
sommes résultat alors
il adapte mais globalement on sent qu'il
est en train de jouer comme ils jouaient
pas ce qu'il ya eu un moment
cette affaire est une affaire routier ce
n'est effectivement là quand il est en
corée du nord il a fait promoteur
immobilière qu'il a commencé ils sont
venus avec une vidéo pour montrer ce que
peut devenir la corée du nord avec le
tourisme avec les plats incroyable alors
cela dit c'est assez intéressant la
rencontre avec kim jong-un parce que
c'est vrai que ça a commencé très tendu
mais personne n'avait parlé de liga et
deux autres dans une pharmacie aussi du
et finalement ça se termine par une par
une rencontre contre assez étonnante
dd on peut se demander qui est le
gagnant de la rencontre ce pas plutôt
kim jong-un que que tu rappes non alors
il ya quinze jours pour le président
américain le le bluff à lui à dieu vous
avez survaleurs parce que oui c'est
quand même difficile de l avait arrondi
vous ne viendrez en prison en gros ce
type est un abruti
il va jamais respecté puis ensuite
peuvent partir à singapour
enfin dans une île les riches à
singapour pour lui serrer la main et de
les taper dans le dos ça fait cher la
main notre président du tape dans le dos
ce que l'invasion d'une demande
il en fait ce qu'il veut en fait ce
qu'il veut moi je suis quand même étonné
de ça et je vais vous dire je
las il va pas con que tron se trompe et
et je reste persuadé que pour lui parce
que lui il à 40% sa population qui est
un malnutrition et c'est très très bien
car aussi une difficulté ou des vhu de
réaction de sa population
donc ils avaient besoin de sortir de
quelque chose mais vous savez tous les
accords de ce grand-père de son père ou
de lui je mens oui il faut se méfier je
m'en méfie il ya probablement derrière
cet accord londres de la chine qui a
envie que peut-être que pour faire des
affaires que la corée du nord se
remettent aussi un peu dans le concert
international existe en tant que tel car
moi qui connaît bien la corée du sud
ils veulent pas être en contact direct
et vos frontières et ils ont 7 7 corée
du nord qui vient entre les deux âmes
j'espère qu'ils cultivent ça mais mais
l'accord parce que cc
dénucléarisation de l'ensemble corée du
nord corée du sud
départ des troupes américaines c'est à
dire c'est plutôt la corée qui gagne
dessus que greta dit et le japon qui se
retrouve un peu seul
j'imagine dans l'accord il ya le départ
des forces américaines oui oui à terme
c'est tout ça c'est évidemment il ya des
conditions mais plus d'attention qu'un
accord oui c'est vrai mais j'ai par des
troupes américaines et services qui
normalement n'a pas dit quand il ya
quelque chose aussi qui relève de la
sémantique mais qui en réalité a
beaucoup de conséquences et que les
états unis ont cédé sur la formulation
de la dénucléarisation
cette dénucléarisation elle devait être
rapide irrémédiable et vérifiable par
l'aï eu a en réalité on a enlevé les
trois mots donc ça veut dire
dénucléarisation progressif probable
éventuelles et ça c'est le symbole même
d'un accord qui n'a aucune force
normative en tout temps qu'une force
pour les autorités de contrôle parce que
on a retiré petit à petit chacun des
termes qui pouvait être un peu
contraignant pour la corée donc à mon
sens on vous dit c'est plutôt encore une
déclaration d'intention oui mais c'est
surtout une déclaration d'intention qui
à mon sens est plutôt en train de servir
la corée c'est peut-être un petit peu de
problèmes d'ego elle je les remets au
centre c'est quand même kim jong-un
voilà celui qui est remis ensemble c'est
kim jong-un et je pense que c'est l'ego
de donald trump qui là est en train de
lui jouer des tours qu'il a voulu
justement jouer le comment j'ai fait le
premier à y arriver mais est ce que
finalement ça n'a pas été un peu le
dindon de la farce il faut il faut se
poser la question alors peut-être face
il ya huit mois tout le monde était là
en train de dire ça va être la guerre
nucléaire ça va être monstrueux etc
c'était une catastrophe et puis la trump
réussi quelque chose et tout de suite on
est en train de dire oui ces dindons de
la farce il est ridicule il s'est fait
avoir
bon je veux dire tous les tous les
présidents ont essayé ce qu'il a ce
qu'il a réussi
c'est le seul encore une fois l'europe
on a réussi à renvoyer jacques lang un
jour en corée du nord qui s'est bien
gardé voilà et nous rendus non mais
qu'est ce que j'attendais qu'est ce que
c'est qu'est-ce que je me manque mais
avaient tenu de l'accord est rien jamais
une japonaise
parce que si des dons américaine se
parts de la région j'avais mes fans
schmerling ne sont pas elles sont pas
partis et la chine et le japon s'est
pour l'instant pas simplement dit
effectivement on va arrêter de faire des
manoeuvres navales à la route et ça va
bien je crois que ça crie ça va nous
coûter moins cher et de corée du sud
voilà mais là on verra bien alors moi je
dis quand même parce que sinon je peux
pas tout à leur parole d'iran
je serai pas juste il faut aussi qu'on
parle à tous ces gens là bien sûr et je
ne peux pas parler qu'ils veulent
soutenir mais il faut non mais c'est pas
parce qu'on parle qu'on soutient voilà
même à l'instant mais il faut qu'on
parle c'est quand le général de gaulle à
plusieurs reprises qu'il a dit ban
surtout quand il a reconnu la chine
vient de faire bon parti pour parler
parce que c'est un grand peuple et que
si il peut ressortir de ces discussions
des discussions ces accords ou
d'un peu plus de paix oui dans ce monde
c'est quand même quelque chose de
diversion pour nous tous parce que c'est
vrai et je peux même aller plus loin
les américains il avait demandé que les
américains soient très près a tapé très
près à taper c'est ça qui est
intéressant dans cet accord c'est que
quelque part la seule chose qui est
intéressant que c'est la photo à la fin
en prouvant que finalement aussi bien
donald trump que kim jong-un devons
arrêter les tweets insultant et ça c'est
une bonne nouvelle pour les relations
internationales de tout le monde mais à
part cela mon avis on n'a pas obtenu
grand chose mais c'est un réchauffement
des relations et c'est toujours lui qui
est alors aussi jeudi par dont deux en
or mais c'est important pour la corée du
sud
oui c'est un mec le premier geste qui
étaient les jeux olympiques avec cette
équipe commune corée du sud et sa soeur
elle non reese ça et donc c'était il ya
il ya quand même une volonté pour la
décorer indivision partie totalement
négatif voile à jadriya il doit y avoir
alors il ya du négatif sud accord des
deux il ya des il ya des questions à des
questions fort mais je suis persuadé
qu'en même que c'est quelque chose pour
la paix dans le monde qui est dans ce
cas et dans ce coin qui est très très
important qui est non négligeable
c'était je faisais la gaffe de fox news
qu'elle rencontre
deux dictateurs ses besoins il ya une
interview de trains foxnews
jeudi jeudi matin alors qu'ils étaient
dithyrambiques sur kim jong-un alors les
journées suis enfin ya quand même
beaucoup de prisonniers politiques a les
droits de l'homme jégun samedi au cobo
faut quand même pas qu'il y avait un
pays comme ça si on n'a pas un peu de
poigne pour une poignée de poignet il ya
la poignée de main avec avec avec
emmanuel macron on a rejoué le celui
qu'ils ne céderaient pas celui qui
dirait la main la plus blanche après là
il ya un côté gamin quand même non pas
commencer à dire du mal
non non mais dans cet abcès tout ça
c'est un peu j'avais des gens souper
tout ça le grand tapez donc dos moi je
regarde des réalisations des réalités
oui doit envoyer les traces et il dans
les deux mâchoires crispées comme ça
vous allez qui sadr a pas c'est moi je
crois qu'il s'agit un peu là dedans
c'est al à l'époque on est en train de
parler des droits des femmes
on a évidemment raison de le faire mais
on parle beaucoup de cette idée que les
femmes et les hommes sont exactement sur
le même logiciel qu'il faut élever une
petite fille comme un petit garçon et
c'est je crois qu'on voit dans des
moments comme ça qu'il ya quand même une
forme de réaction masculine avec cette
manière aussi don à donald trump de
gérer les relations internationales
côté enfantin c'est un petit peu une
manière de rouler des mécaniques il ya
voilà il ya ce côté je domine la
situation par ma force et jeh j'ai les
épaules plus que toi de matthew alors
voilà
c'est un peu ça m'a interloqué de la
part d' emmanuel macron mais finalement
cette étude va céder c'est une guerre
d'école c'est une guerre des coques
finalement conseil voit avec cette
poignée de main voilà cherabi un coût
des pellicules aussi aux artistes alors
qu'ils n'avaient alors on peut on peut
passer à la situation française
éventuellement alors c'est vrai on a
peut-être l'impression là il ya un
grandissement du nombre de mécontents +
20 % je prends un an de pouvoir il ya
des reculs sur le glyphosate
sur l'élevage des poulets en batterie
par exemple de quelqu'un quand même
important sur l'interdiction de l'huile
de palme aussi est ce que est ce qu'il
ya un petit tournant dans le quinquennat
ou parce que après tout ça fait partie
de la vie normale d'un gouvernement voit
sûrement du sens des réalités parce que
on est tous contre le glyphosate mais
par quoi on le remplace est ce que
peut-on dire aux agriculteurs en nous
disant laisser ça c'est fini on est tous
et moi le premier contre l'élevage des
poules en batterie mais ce que les gens
sont prêts à payer un poulet 40 euros le
kg au lieu d'acheter 10 euros la perte
de poulet c'est ça aussi qu'il faut dire
et un gouvernement il un peu obligé de
dire ça y est c'est bien joli de montrer
des images chocs et ses hauts risques
quand on l'achète quand on achète un
poulet à 8 euros dans un supermarché on
se doute bien qu'il n'est pas élevée en
plein et enfin vers après faut savoir ce
qu'on achète
c est ce qu'on peut se payer est ce que
tout le monde peut se payer un poulet à
20 euros le kilo je suis pas sûr donc
voilà c'est bien facile de jouer les
offusqués de tout dix ans on arrête ça
on arrête ça on arrête ça mais après
qu'est ce qu'on fait quoique et puis
faut tout que tout le monde arrête en
place les ciseaux exactement nous
laisser en importe après mais par
exemple sur le bio toute la nourriture
bio qui arrivent de l'étranger hors
europe n'est pas contre la contre allée
de la même façon c'est-à-dire que ya un
pays qui veut tout fait des bananes en
inde afrique du sud n importe où nous
envoie les bananes il met une étiquette
bio et l'europe via basse et ils ont dit
que c'était bios et bio il n'y a
absolument aucune certitude ça peut être
nous ré de pesticides c'est c'est eux
qui décident dans leur pays que le bio
pour eux c'est ça mais c'est pas le même
que vont nous donc c'est monstrueux
c'est pareil et l'europe est encore là
dessus et hyper faible nous on a
d'énormes on interdit certains
pesticides en france mais pas en espagne
et comment comme vous tous que les
agriculteurs et les sur le glyphosate
est vrai que c'est assez compliqué de
s'en passer du jour au lendemain pour
les agriculteurs
possible pour nous agriculteurs des
églises au coeur traverse une période
très difficile
prenons ça aussi en cause avec beaucoup
de travail en étant obligé ne pas partir
en vacances parce que le sable il y
manque de cupidité et ainsi de suite
donc il faut aussi le ladies arrive
quelquefois est libéré pour bloquer les
stations d'essence
un truc c'est curieux c'est comme
l'époque où ils sont censés bosser et
six mois ce taux que si les agriculteurs
peuvent aller déverser du film de zurich
efficace qui a raccompagné est réparé
tout va bien sûr c'est sur toutes les
stations de service c'est bon c'est sûr
mine de palme c'est quand même c'est
quand même un mauvais coup pour les
producteurs de colza un oui mais enfin
cela vous parlait il ya deux minutes
d'écologie et de trucs c'est quand même
curieux de lutter contre un très un truc
absolument pas ça non plus parce que le
colza qui vendent à total je dire c'est
un colza qui ne sert pas à nourrir les
animaux ou les hommes et du coup on
importe de l'huile de palme pour
remplacer le colza qui vendent enfin je
veux dire c'est c'est un circuit fermé
qui est hyper malsain donc j'ai un
combat d'arrière-garde des agriculteurs
la fois franchement ça n'a pas de sens
j'ai d'ailleurs elle en est consciente
parce que c'est une femme
là c'est une femme qui est à la tête de
la fédé soeur et baal en est consciente
williams moi je le dis j'aime beaucoup
de rural j'aime beaucoup ce pays il
équilibre global du pays entre grandes
villes il faut l'agriculture française
doit encore évoluer
messieurs mais sincèrement donc prévalu
et je ne dis pas qu'on truc pas du tout
tu alors bénéfices à peu prendre du
temps mais ça peut prendre du temps et
c'est pour les faux et évasion modérée
en ce qui concerne la suppression
immédiate
bafa les trois ans sur une des choses
n'étaient pas immédiates
d'ici cinq ans si je mets dans ses 5 ans
qui ont été décidées la france où les
trois ans alors insulté trois ans et
finalement ces cinq ans donc
alors cela dit de l'agriculture faire en
sorte que ça soit dans les trois ans
mais ça n'est plus inscrit dans la
réponse de la majorité est là je te
rejoins pensez pas inintéressante c'est
que la majorité a clairement fait
comprendre que elle était liée par des
accords au niveau de l'union européenne
et que comme tu dis pour arriver à
remplacer certaines substances certaines
pratiques de l'agriculture
maintenant c'est quand même quelque
chose qui réclame une position commune
alors est ce que c'est une manière aussi
de se cacher derrière l'union européenne
pour ne pas décider
il ya toujours un souci en matière
d'environnement d'agriculture c'est ses
voeux pieux qu'on va voter en disant il
faut mieux respecter la vie animale etc
et je suis d'accord avec toi
malheureusement l'effectivité ensuite
elle n'est jamais au rendez vous donc là
il ya au moins une forme de démarches
d'honnêteté en disant si on décide ça on
va se mettre en délicatesse par rapport
à des accords qu'on a avec l'union
européenne et au moins on est sûr de
parler d'une voix commune
en attendant que ça se fasse donc il ya
quand même ils n'ont démarche de
s'insérer dans la loi éventuellement un
seuil à trois ans avec une progressivité
jusqu'à 5 ans qui est les 52 décidé je
pense qu'il y avait d'autres solutions
plutôt que de dire on fait rien et on
dit rien et on met pas de choses que
diplôme même si à mon avis la légitimité
de nicolas hulot au gouvernement en tout
cas la ccl coup sûr présent on verra on
verra cet été est-ce qu'il tiendra
mais votre avis l'adoma boulot là moi je
regarde globalement l'ensemble de
l'intérêt de l'ensemble de mon pays et
je le dis comme je pense des mesures
brusque c'est lui d'ailleurs qui avait
proposé trois ans à la france quand il a
été initialement
attention de ne pas abîmer cet équilibre
précaire entre le rural qui souffrent
peut raconter tout ce qu'on veut alors
pas tous gras tous même si avec la base
de l'alva hb parce que c'est pas
seulement par me dire ça avec beaucoup
de respect pour eux et comme auprès des
tgv et vous dé traverser la france la
france est propre
parce que ce sont des agriculteurs qu'il
va le faire
qui va le faire alors je dis pas que je
sais qu'il faut simplement des points
mais quand même la france est magnifique
tgv vous regardez à droite moi nous
c'est magnifique il en est un pays
agricole mystérieux n'est alors c'est
moi nos racines quand même mais c'est
quand même notre histoire
alors ils bloquent aussi un peu pour les
poulets on a quand même vu des
situations absolument pas trop raide
pour tuer les bêtes pas partout c'est
parti et tables de non plus a eu lieu
dans ces parties habitables non plus
donc moi je suis un modéré dans cette
affaire et je suis pas toujours d'accord
avec macron particulier quand ils
augmentent à siéger pour les petites
retraites soit disons pas mais pour des
petites retraites
mais là je ne suis pas opposé à ce qu'on
met du temps à l'ombre du show lors de
ne rien puisqu'on parlait de donné que
la ville où c'est exactement son
problème
est-ce qu'il vaut mieux faire une
politique comme ça deux m'ont dit on
veut tout obtenir tout de suite trouvé
ce qu'il vaut mieux faire des petits pas
cessé de vrais problèmes et c'est son
problème à lui
tweet tout de suite je pense tout de
suite on n'obtiendra rien qu'est ce
qu'il ya comme produit pour mettre hélas
c'est encore dans des dents des études
j'ai un jeu donc tout de suite non mais
moi je suis aussi d'accord avec vous
j'aurais commune donner des perspectives
attractives a maintenant sa perspective
parce que on sent bien que d'une société
vers laquelle on va quand même
dès qu'on souhaiterait il faut dire que
la note voilà des fonds de la nature -
deux mois de violences sur les animaux
enfin on sent bien le interdire quand
même les produits qui sont cancérogènes
ces jeunes sont concourir que nous nos
jeunes c'est très simple une défense de
la nature beaucoup plus important que
bien sûr ne soyez pas trop occupé mais
là non mais de façon un peu général les
agriculteurs donc sont impactés par cela
mais tous les métiers que en france son
impact est soit par des réformes choisi
par les évolutions technologiques etc et
je compte chaque métier doit se remettre
en cause chaque métier doit avancer et
imaginer le futur plutôt que de rester
voilà droit dans ses bottes en attendant
tu attends que le ciel nous tombe sur la
tête
là il faut aller autrement un peu plus
comme ça non mais je vois par exemple je
discutais avec un commissaire aux
comptes une réforme qui va arriver pour
les commissaires aux comptes
ils vont perdre à peu près certains
cabinets vont perdre 40% de 40% de leur
chiffre d'affaires
oui parce qu'on va supprimer les
commissariats ou contenant dans la
maison en faisant l'un d'eux en bougeant
des seuils donc ils vont perdre 40% de
leur chiffre d'affaires donc là c'est
pareil il était là sur deux a cessé de
l'acquis mais non par là aujourd'hui
c'est ce qu'il faut se dire c'est que
dans tout métier rien est acquis qu'il
fallait absolument il faut se projeter
et qu'il faut anticiper la réforme du
notariat
c'est la catastrophe finalement
idalement finalement l'analyse
aujourd'hui je pense spécialistes mais
finalement la réforme du notariat qui a
été beaucoup plus ouvert je vois pas
donc monsieur existe une justement de
faire les débuts de la montée du
mécontentement mais ça c'est assez
habituel
d'abord c'est moins fort que ça n'était
pas sarkozy pour hollande et en même
temps il y as on sent bien que la
contestation du relais grève la sncf
ça ne prend pas quoi c'est à dire que
peu de montées de mécontentement mais
mais baissent de la constestation non
bah oui parce que je pense que comme le
disait très justement flanc c'est tout
tout tout les secteurs doivent bouger
vous voit bien qu'il va falloir bouger
donc on est chacun pour soi ces
mécontents mais en même temps tout le
monde est conscient qu'il faut que ça
vous pouvez vous le savez autant que on
n'est pas content mais un débat oui mais
de façon c'est la fin il faut les faire
là bas quand ça tombe sur soi en un
moral quand on échoue mines au débat et
c'est pas bien mais le cheminot il est
bien content qu'on réforme les impôts
qu'on réforme tel truc en avant le
talent donc à titre personnel on est
mécontent mais je pense que c'est comme
vous le dites quand on aime son pays
quand on est attaché au pays en diva il
faut bien que ça bouge
donc voilà c'est sûr parce qu'à nous
pour moi c'est ça c'est ça une
explication c'est que les gens mais là
mais mais mais
moi je regarde les choses de près et je
discute avec eux le présent du cdh avec
gérard larcher sur ça il ya quand même
alors je suis d'accord avec vous le
poids donné par la réforme est plus
important que la comptable décalé une
certaine mieux s'il avait raison il ya
beaucoup plus de points voit bien on a
bien vu le travail regarder ça a amené
des gens de réalmont la sncf ça y est ça
va être votée puisqu'ils sont mis
d'accord ils ont fait la tournée
mondiale c'est la fin de la reprise qui
veut dire et vous avez un français
alors si c'est parce qu'il a des bons de
gratuit pour les 7 cf
mais globalement on est tous pour que
les choses changent parce que c'est la
catastrophe
a la sncf les résultats sont
catastrophiques alors c'est
catastrophique peut dire ben non on
apprend de ses progrès et c'est comme
pour les compagnies aérienne alitalia
des ou à l'italien mais dégage une
maison donc en france air france
moi je suis d'accord avec nous devons
penser d'abord à on peut avoir de
position personnelles mais d'abord notre
pays
l'intérêt de notre pays alors une
application aussi d'une directive
européenne pourrait l'appliquer aussi un
mois je pense que là pour le moment on
est rentré dans des contestations
sectoriel est ce que ça peu voilà on est
en train de montrer la photo du
rééquilibrage social peut rencontrer
quelque chose de plus vaste où vous
parliez des réformes fiscales tout à
l'heure et je suis totalement en accord
avec vous quand on parle de la csg quand
on parle de l'exit tax
il ya certains messages qui sont envoyés
par le gouvernement
et par emmanuel macron qui peuvent
conduire à une révolte plus profondes
des français du volet du côté de sa
gauche justement est du volet social
est-ce que les menaces que ça pour va
démarrer vont prendre mais si ça ne
prendra pas prédit ça c'est à présent et
ils ont bien si elle est servie cas
d'essayer de dire il ya eu des
manifestations avec les insoumis et les
manifestations avec des syndicats unis
c'est vrai ça on peut pas dire ça non
mais ça n'a pas été un succès parce que
il manuel mata a annoncé que la première
année voilà les réformes qu'il allait
brûler il a été élu pour ça
il les a faites il a fait il a avancé
l'agent avec une évolution générale est
que maintenant il est censé on va voir
ce que ça va nous alors avancé la jambe
nageant que ceux-ci agent social s'est
solidement assiste au 4-3-3 économistes
important qu'ils ont conseillé et qui
l'ont conseillé qui sont encore à lyon
martin et jean pisani ferry jean pisani
ferry qui est écrit même sur son
programme et économique et qui disent au
fond il faut une correction de la
politique économique qui trouvera au de
flexibilité passé de sécurité tron
libéralisme pas cette social est
libéralisée est ce qu'il ya un plan
comme ça c'est qu'il ferait qu' il faut
d'abord transformé la france et puis
ensuite une fois que les résultats sont
acquis il ya peut-être un peu moins de
chômage etc
donnez un volet social plus plus
important ou est-ce que où est ce que
comme dit philippe à lyon il fait la
politique de juppé mais rééquilibrage
social chez arrivée rééquilibrage à
gauche
il s'agit des infos s'agit du 2e du 200
m en même temps oui mais c'est pour
donner des gages à la gauche
franchement tu dois tout le monde le
sait j'ai pas caché il a donné beaucoup
à la droite et au centre la seule preuve
c'est quand on regarde les électeurs de
l air il est chargé
je les fais ça la semaine dernière on
s'aperçoit que qui séduit que une bonne
partie du secteur
heller
donc il ya quand même alors une parti
socialiste tel état on dit pas que
keller sur le tabac d'état tant que ce
menteur des voyez ce que je veux dire ce
qu'il monte mais les économistes en
disant faites des choses qui marquent un
peu plus à gauche
vous avez été lui aussi parce qu'il ya
quand même une partie de la gauche qui a
voté beau macro d'idra qui a pourtant
importante est ce qui vient de la route
oui mais mais mais mais moi je suis un
peu dans votre analyse
pardon voiture passe ici est votre
analyse brecht un gain de temps il ya
deux chambres d'hôtes en mer allez on
modernise ce pays on le remet sur les
bons rails c'est de mombris jamais
brillé ce qu'il veut dire
et puis ensuite peut-être qu ancien
trader il a voulu et a conduit hier il
avoue lui hier avec l'histoire des
lunettes des appareils auditifs et ça et
donc qu'il a voulu mais je pense que ça
sincèrement c'est pas que je suis contre
1 puisque afflelou est très content il a
dit mais je vais vous dire tout ce qu'il
a fait c'est plutôt une approche de
droite ou de chance il va pouvoir offrir
un tout petit peu plus à gauche son
discours parce que on parle beaucoup sur
le plateau on est en train de dire
droite gauche alors c'est moi qui sont
devenu tabou 1 depuis le en marche il
avait bien précisément je me souviens de
son discours devant les écoliers où il
avait eu cette pédagogie en dix ans
justement on ne va plus penser les
questions par rapport à la droite ou à
la gauche on veut en faire des questions
universelles si vraiment il veut avancer
ce cap là le social la protection
sociale or l'association cette vidéo
quand même très étonnante sur la
protection sociale puisqu'il prépare son
discours
sur sur ce thème et on voit la
préparation du disque ou et c'est là
qu'ils ont laissé filmer c'est ni en
misant sur les réseaux sociaux par
l'elysée où il dit ça coûte un fric fou
et ça ne l'est il ya toujours autant de
dingue
il a raison lacaune et hautbois podium
c'est quand même nom mais alors c'est
juste un constat alors c'est à présent
il y avait quelqu'un peut dire qu'il a
tort des mois il est patent alors ce que
je voudrais bien pour des résultats sous
qui sont au rsa par exemple alors
qu'attendez fait ça yann à 100 combien
sont sortis et s'éteint c'est à une
analyse qu'il fait les mais ça va encore
pardon puisqu'on parle de marquage ça va
encore marquer le 28 mai abbas aux
saucisses et en effet de l'efficacité
qui est en cause - le au fond l'argent
que l'efficacité mais ce qui est très
étonnant c'est la manière de communiquer
là dessus cette vidéo mise en ligne par
l'elysée non organisée récemment fausse
fausse fausse caméra café voire cdu
volontairement les grenats kg a failli
dire il n'a pas de mal
[Rires]
non mais c'est très étonnant comme
manière de communication non câble cette
fausse heures et c'est la première année
chant fou si la première année
moi j'ai persuadé qu'il faut qu'ils font
s'ils font de seafrance et c'est chez
elle c'est dans la dernière période
en fin de deuxième encore un an 12 mois
et ensuite il faudra falloir et je pense
que c'est là qu'ils veulent c'est là où
devrait donner plus d'équilibré de
perception parce qu'elles vont faire
attention
oui c'est la perception que les contrats
annoncés comme pour la tempête
attention aux mesures fiscales c'est là
dessus à mon avis qu'il a quand même
quelque chose à jouer au niveau de sa
légitimité et après il vient un peu un
peu moins jupitérien avec cette vidéo là
parce que elle voit en bras de chemise
c'est un peu style obama connaît son
truc alors qu'il voudra il voulait pas
montrer il avait toujours dire on ne
doit pas montrer comment se fait la
politique voilà pas fini toutes ces
réunions font filmer
voilà mais la bras de chemise irakien un
langage assez qualifiés change un peu je
savais pas réussi à sarkozy quand même
non il ya des choses assez semblables
d'ailleurs je vous dis certains disent
autres tiennent notre abri dormant à
l'ordre est un très bon on a su aller au
mot son mondial c'est jeudi et la france
ou samedi il ya en fait nous rêver le
demandent les jours d'eau il ya deux
choses qui me
font pas rêver mais qui m'interpelle
c'est que le valorisation des équipes
c'est l'équipe de france qui vous le
plus cher rien il ya un livre 1
milliards actuels on additionne tout est
beaucoup plus que l'espagne beaucoup
plus que l'allemagne donc fait l'équipe
la plus chère du monde c'est l'équipe de
france c'est le premier truc ça derrière
du chef je pense que l'esprit non mais
qu'est ce qu'on est derrière le mot le
plus cher c'est le coût des actions
engagées
ça fait plus d'un billard du coup des 22
joueurs c'est vrai que la terre se pose
pas et l'espagne est franchement en
dessous et puis après ce qui est gagné
sur l'argent des doigts ça c'est bien
et puis le deuxième chiffre c'est que
seulement 4% des français pensent qu'on
peut le gagner
oui ça c'est laisser curieux 98
pour beaucoup de spécialistes du foot la
france fait partie des favoris mais en
fait pour l'opinion publique et des
dessins mais bon après c'est un peu
l'opinion publique
savez-vous gagner un match ça va ça va
être la folie donc un peu restés sur
l'ancien logiciel est ce que c'est pas
98 ce qui nous a laissé une forme de
d'image tellement des finales que
regarder cette île de france de 98 qui a
joué mardi soir sur tmc million et demi
gens qui ont regardé les affaires qui va
jusque sur le plan politique bien sûr
parce que moi je suis d'accord
le parisien fait pour aider les français
ont besoin ont besoin de rêver les
français râlent or d'une part faut pas
que des rêveurs ne veut pas dire ça mais
les foncières bodin de rêver et il
considère que le moment est difficile
les moments de réforme est toujours
difficile
1 parce qu'il ya un bon et des marqueurs
sont plus au même endroit mais moi je
reste persuadé que c'est un peuple qui a
que nous devons faire rêver alors soit
colagne des globalement c'est quelque
chose de positif
on est quand même dans un équilibre de
la société qui est extrêmement fragile
est extrêmement extrêmement fragile avec
peut-être un petit retour d'optimisme
quand même et ça ça peut contribuer en
effet à 98 avait fait du bien la paix a
la cote ces du monde donc ça aurait pu
faire de l'union à la cote de jeu ce
schéma qui abrite mais il n'a pas
transformé
émile parce que et et deux et quatre ans
plus tard il va quand même le pen au
deuxième tour elle pas la fin et le
blanc beur donc faut faire attention à
ça
simplement mc ren a dit il faut gagner
ces questions sinon en effet grand pays
de loser a toujours dire c'est de
participer ou non aux sports l'important
c'est de gagner
jamais vu ça une bolt au départ du truc
bon aller j'y vais mais je participe à
non la rivale pour gagner il gagne ça me
paraît évident elle a encore une fois on
attaque et macro et qu'est ce que c'est
que cette façon de la raison corrèze
non mais j'ai pas que vous l'attaqué
mais il a été attaqué gt gt invités j'ai
un copain qui va vers invités il y avait
invités à l'algérien qui venait pas
ghislaine place le ministre de
l'intérieur dit rien il ya une place à
l'avant parce que je voulais mettre
paquet les îles 02 juillet et il me dit
je dis d'abord je veux bien venir si j'y
vais par les tops en commun parce qu'il
va mais c'était un moment que je
n'oublierai jamais et chupa un conte
footeux c'est non mais sérieux notre
évolution
c'était une ambiance et que sa destinée
d une ambiance incroyable même à la
sortie les plats les voitures de
policiers avaient mis leurs oeufs se
refaire incroyable et c'est quelque
chose que j'ai l'air reste c'est pour ça
que je crois dans mon pays parce que je
crois qu'on peut avoir
et dans notre histoire des moments
difficiles je raterais dernier étudié 1
1 c'est la guerre est ce qu'on a fait
comme on est français on fait parce que
tout est beau tout est beau le roman est
beau et puis aussi des moments où on est
capable de faire des grandes choses
c'est un peuple capable de faire des
grandes choses
alors là leur demande et ib attendait
allez-y ça lui coûte une fortune à vous
avez dit gagner merci infiniment merci
beaucoup
dezeen à florence martel et jean charles
a jauni et à bientôt pour un nouveau
numéro de paf
[Musique]